taking a selfie I am recreating Michael
Jackson's Thriller I will be recreating
Missy Elliott's under construction to
score by the Fugees Diana Ross's debut
solo album dirty mind by Prince the
album cover I'm recreating is the Janet
Jackson self-entitled
album Solange Knowles a seat at the
table
we got Outkast the album is Stankonia
mike is going to be big boy yeah and
rich is gonna be on 30,000 my hair's a
little short right now so am I gonna get
to wear wig like all right on the album
cover you see the boom box you see the
graffiti you see the brick wall in the
background her in the trashcan her kicks
like she's giving you that old-school
3d hip-hop bill and letting you know
this is an album that I'm paying homage
to the greats and paying homage to the
hip-hop roots the score was actually the
first album I ever bought I was 6 I use
my little short money yeah I asked my
cousin cuz she had the cassette and she
wouldn't let me borrow it when I look at
that album cover it's just like
celebration of blackness I think it's
really powerful because it's like this
black woman she has the clips in her
hair and her hair is impressed or
anything it is natural and she's just
like I don't care how I'm supposed to be
looking this is how I'm doing it this
album covers everything those pictures
are everything and they're so powerful
it created a whole new world kind of for
a lot of female artists and when I first
saw it like I just remember just being
like so drawn to it because there's just
something like very alluring about Diana
Ross in general but like especially on
this cover because there's like the
subtle confidence that draws me to her
we used to go to a record store and my
hometown and I remember they had it like
blowing up like a big like a big poster
but I just remember thinking like this
dude is cool to say look like he is
looking at me and saying do not try me
do not [ __ ] with me because I will take
your girl I remember when I first saw it
I really didn't think anything of it but
later in life as I got older I looked at
it and I was just like oh crap
it's an American flag but you have the
black background and then the white
stars on top of it
which for me means like America was kind
of built on the backs of black people
yeah that's my favorite part of the
cover because I feel like the cover
itself is just like them being like this
is our America first time I saw this
album cover I thought that he is
hungover Oh waking up from a party and
she's simultaneously hot and cold at the
same time if I saw somebody wearing a
biker jacket in the speedo I'd be like
what's going on this guy's mine he seems
a little confused but confident looking
right at the camera I'm really excited
to recreate the look with the natural
hair
I'm hype I'm not nervous at all there's
always been in the back of my mind all
these insecurities so I don't know if
this might be a way of kind of letting
those insecurities go or if it might
help me I'm excited to dress up in a
speedo and a biker jacket at work oh wow
everybody came in for this one I am
excited to recreate this because like
she is one of the most iconic artists
like in American history and she is a
black woman as well and she's like one
of the first huge black divas and I feel
like she basically like created like the
template that all of these other pop
stars basically go by I'm [ __ ]
excited
dude I'm excited and nervous about
wearing pants I'm assuming I'm about to
like wear a wig he's got like the perm
doubt you can wear no there's no later
I'm definitely excited to kind of step
back into this moment that Michael did I
guess he was like what 24 or 25 he
literally he defined the industry
oh my god you must be killed si you know
I never thought this day would come but
now that it's here I feel like Missy and
I will finally be the best friends that
we've been destined to be so Melissa
when this comes out when this is ready
you know let's get lunch let's get
drinks I love you I think that it was
very specific to women of color and
women of color who get their hair done
we all know where to buy those clips and
we all know where hairdresser keeps
those clips just like seeing that there
is already an instant connection with me
and my friends they're totally just
surrounded by shadows I think that
speaks a lot to the black experience but
they're shining beyond the shadows and
they're surely wouldn't you see them
just like all the things that you know
our people are surrounded by yeah if
this album cover could talk
I think it would just be like [ __ ] you
this is who I am and this is what I came
to do like is beautiful I know that and
I will stand by it every day but to have
an artist on such a large platform of
tears and to be able to use his platform
to make a statement like that you know
that that goes leaps and bounds and that
says so much the vibe and the attitude
and the confidence I think we should all
have that on every day because as
Michael shows you like it could take the
place I just love inspiring figures she
is definitely like a huge one and not
only music history but just like black
history if the album could talk I'd
probably think that it would just say
you know I am a woman this is me and
I am fierce powerful and strong haven't
won a speedo in a while ever maybe what
is feminine right and I think that it's
kind of funny because now in 2017 it's
like Oh gender is such like an old
concept and so I think that kind of
blurring those lines is a little bit
ahead of his time she laid the
foundation for me as a black girl to
hold my head high to be confident with
whatever I wear whatever I look like and
how I present myself
[Music]